one of the thing here is from the daily
wire it says security guard travis
mcgivern um
testified monday that he had to re he
had to remove johnny depp from a
situation due to the actor's ex-wife
amber heard physically assaulting him
heard allegedly punched depp in the face
during the incident through a can of red
bull at the actor and tried to spit on
him
depp is suing the aquaman actress for
more than 50 million dollars over
alleged defamation stemming from an
op-ed heard penned at the washington
post claiming to be a victim of domestic
violence hurt his countersued for more
than 100 million dollars herself
um
give her and testified at some point i
witnessed miss heard through a red bull
can that struck mr depp in the back at
that point i moved closer mr depp i
didn't want my client to get hit with
anything else their verbal onslaught
continued from both of them misheard
through something else either a purse or
a bag and i was able to knock it away so
it didn't hit
depp at one point she spit at him
and a lot of verbal vitriol from both of
them
and then he says that he had to get
johnny depp out of the situation for his
own safety
now
this this is the latest out of this
trial and um here's my my my point about
this
now i'm
it's good that it seems like most people
who have followed the trial between
amber heard and johnny depp
um
are realizing that this is not the the
simple picture that amber heard
and her advocates wanted to paint where
you know she's the victimized woman and
he's the evil man and all that i think
most people are realizing that it's it's
more complicated than that
but then you have people that are going
too far to the other end of the spectrum
here and are coming fully to johnny
depp's defense and they're fully on his
side and amber hurd is the is the
villain here
no there are
and i say this as someone i admit
haven't i haven't followed the case
the story that closely
but i just know because this is a
general principle that is almost always
true not always but almost always true
in a you know in a divorce situation
marriage falling apart something like
this
there is very rarely a clear good guy
and a clear bad guy
you know they both can recall situations
where one person was the good guy and
one one person was the bad guy
but that's the thing they both have
evidence of that they both have examples
they can present and then they're just
throwing those examples back and forth
and sometimes they're throwing physical
objects as well
because in the vast majority of cases
um it takes more than one person to make
a marriage fall apart
which is why it's
normally quite absurd to take sides
especially when it's celebrities it's
people you don't even know
even when it's a couple that you do know
taking sides when the marriage is
falling apart is usually a bad move
because it means you're getting you're
getting the story from one person and
they're just telling their side of it
and they're not going to tell you all
the terrible stuff that they've done
but when it's celebrities
like it's just it's guaranteed that
they're both total scumbags
johnny depp
has already been divorced multiple times
and uh and i do know this much about him
he left the mother of his children to go
shack up with this amber heard character
and then a year later the marriage fell
apart
marriage barely lasted a year so he left
his family for this woman and the
marriage falls apart
so that already means he cannot be the
the flat out good guy here which doesn't
make amber hurt a good person it just
means they're both bad guys
like it almost doesn't matter what
happened in this particular marriage you
left your family for this woman
you abandoned your kids
so you're already the bad guy there's no
recovering that
so and that just makes it a little bit
simpler uh they're both probably
scumbags and uh also by the way johnny
depp
if you're a conservative defending him
he almost certainly hates your guts and
would never come to your defense if he
ever if he if he cared enough to say
anything about you which he wouldn't so
another thing to keep in mind if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up and share it with all your
friends